what is with the guys running laps
including the coaches and then i saw
some guys doing it individually as well
well there's consequences on the field
for making mistakes in a game that costs
you five 10 or 15 yards
you know where practice has to be
consequence so we learn how to deal with
our mistakes
when's the last time you saw um guys
teammates doing penalty laps because of
mistakes
uh i don't know
to be honest uh i don't know but hey you
know we're really
focusing on being a detailed team and
holding each other accountable and
the little things matter and you know i
guess that comes with territory
joe judge first saquon barkley's second
talking about the new dynamic in new
york for the first time really since the
days of rex ryan remember hard knocks 10
years ago yeah
they would all do push-ups if somebody
made a mistake including woody johnson
the owner of the team if he happened to
be hanging around when the mistake was
made
you know i understand the mindset
i understand the mentality i still don't
know whether or not it works
on the proverbial or literal grown-ass
man
yeah that making someone run making
someone do push-ups
treating them like their high school or
college players
i don't know that that's gonna fly chris
uh your first reaction when you hear
that joe judge
new sheriff in town making guys run when
they make mistakes well
uh you know i'm not shocked okay this is
the new england way
i mean this is a guy that's been in new
england and came from alabama and nick
saban and
yeah they're detailed in practice they
don't want mistakes
you know and for you know joe judge and
everything like that
and what you question you know is that
good to do
to grown-ass men like you're saying yeah
you got to have the right way about you
as a leader too
to make it effective right you know if
you're constantly just you know
whipping the guys run run run run you
know yeah it's going to kind of fall on
empty ears and guys are going to start
to block you out
you know if you have a good way about
you as a leader as a communicator
showing you care about these guys yet
still also
you know driving a driving a hard
bargain as far as what he expects
on the football field i think the
players can accept it mike
and in new england that's the one thing
that jumped out to me you've heard me
say it before
bill is much more of a players coach
than people realize
he does a great job just from what i saw
of going around
door his door was always open to them he
talks to them all those things
but i i mean within one of my first few
days there ever
and i knew this went on a little bit
because i played with josh mcdaniels and
denver but i think one of my first days
working in new england
ota brady and whoever the center was at
that time
they you know botched the quarterback
center exchange snap
and bill just goes run run like he
doesn't you know
say the names and there goes brady and
the center
there they're going to run down all the
way acro down the field
circle around the goal post and come
back and then you know to have to jump
back into practice right after that and
take reps
so that'll make players be more
disciplined because now you go
well damn i'm tired i'm thinking a lot
now i got to go run
and go right into practice and that'll
make life difficult and certainly get
you on your you know your
your p's and q's to be more detailed
well two things about that first of all
if you tell tom brady go run around the
goal post and come back it's going to be
45 minutes later so it's a nice break
for everyone to practice
good you're good second second yeah when
bill belichick says go run i know
back in the time that you were there
right he's got five rings
yeah he's got the two he won with the
giants and he's got the first three one
with the patriots
so it gives him the credibility to be
that
task master task t-a-s-s
k-master right yeah he can be that guy
because he's got the pelts on the wall
and or the pellets on the horse we have
agreed to disagree on the appropriate
term there
but this is the prime example of what
happens when someone
leaves the nest in new england to be a
head coach
because what i saw yesterday immediate
comparisons
of joe judge to josh mcdaniels in denver
brandon stokely pointed it out on
twitter shannon sharp even though he
didn't play for the broncos when
mcdaniels was there
he said this isn't going to work in
relation to judge and
you know these guys who are with
belichick who think they're going to be
different
who think they're going to be their own
man who think they're going to do it
their own way what they don't realize
is being in that pressure cooker
being in that environment it changes
your dna
to the point where even if you're trying
your damn just to be the exact opposite
of bill belichick you still are bill
belichick you still are doing it the way
he does it
because that's your normal that's your
context
that's how you think it's supposed to be
and the problem is
until you get the pelts on the wall and
or the pellets on the horse
if that attitude i get it does not
result in you winning games
you're going to lose the team right
you're going to lose your job look at
what matt patricia's going through in
detroit year three
this is it for him it's up or it's out
because
guys didn't take to the patriot way so
that's what's going on well yeah
you're right you're right that's where
you know that's where that's why i was
you know kind of delving into that
subject of you got to have the right way
to communicate with the players too you
can't always look like you know you're
the dictator
of the football team you know or or you
win
or you win or you win you can be
you can be bill belichick you can be
johnny anti-social
and it works as long as you win because
the proof is
in the proverbial or literal pudding no
doubt
no doubt but we're not there yet so he's
got to also be able to
keep them focused and still feeling the
right energy here before you even get to
play a game or win
or show that you know this type of
structure correlates to wins in a
football season
this is never easy for football players
especially the modern day football
player
you know old school stuff has gone out
the window as
we know i mean it's just a different age
in football so
yeah this saquon barkley when's the last
time somebody made you made you run a
lap i don't know i've been the best
player on my team since i was
four so i never had to run laps like
he'd be he's probably like what but he's
gonna run a lap here soon with joe judge
you're gonna drop a ball he's gonna fall
start and practice do whatever it is
but that's where i just go to again
because we're not playing games and
we're not gonna see results
you know you can't draw that hard line
in the sand
maybe like maybe other belichick
disciples have done
you know you gotta make sure you got
that fine line about yeah being a good
communicator showing the players you
care about them by also
you know driving a hard bargain on the
practice field and i do think that joe
judge
has the ability to do that he's got the
people skills to do that
he's got a young team to mold here in a
lot of ways too some good young leaders
to where hopefully this doesn't turn
into
a you know michael strahan what the hell
is going on with tom coughlin type of
thing here before the season even starts
and as we know uh that was the giants
and things turned out pretty well when
the
good old tommy boy coughlin started
driving a hard bargain in new york too
so you know i hope the players can hang
it no no what vision is history
challenge flag no it didn't work out
well in new york until tom coughlin
faced with the fact that he was going to
lose his job if he didn't change his
ways
changed his way he bent back a little
bit you're right and became
he been a light broke in half he did
everything he could
to relate to the players when he knew
his career was hinging on it
and it worked i mean look tom coughlin
on the hot seat was one of the best
coaches in nfl history because he was on
the hot seat twice
2007 2011. both years they won the super
bowl so
you know you have to be willing to to
break from
whatever it is that is guiding you to be
that over-the-top
drill sergeant because that doesn't work
anymore that doesn't fly anymore
unless you win that is the key now let
me ask you this chris
because we tell your horror stories from
time to time
based upon your experiences with john
gruden and he seems like the kind of guy
given that
that scowl and given his demeanor and
given just his way that he would be
like this that he would have punishments
that he would dole out for mistakes
was is the punishment with gruden just
that you have to deal with him or does
he make you do things
no no i think he kind of just hit it as
you were sitting there talking about i'm
going you know guru doesn't the type
that
made you run laps or doing anything like
that gruden was the type that was going
to drive you crazy
if you made a mistake he was going to
drive you crazy he was going to talk
about it
during that practice he was in a needle
with it needle you with it at the end of
the practice as you're walking off the
field
you're going to see him in the lunchroom
later he's gonna needle you again and
roll his eyes at you and call you a dolt
or a dummy
you're gonna go into the meeting room
he's gonna give it to you one more time
he's not gonna forget it and let you off
the hook
until basically you prove that okay i've
been fixed and that's not a problem
anymore
so yeah he didn't discipline that way he
disciplined you by driving you crazy to
where you went
man i don't want that damn guy in my ear
all the time
so all that yeah did he pull me off the
field during practice once
uh because of quarterback center
exchange and told us to get out of there
yes
he did and it pissed me off and that was
one of the few times i threw some four
letter words back at him because the
ball just
dragged on the ground and he kicked me
out of all the practice i nobody could
have got that center exchange snap but
everybody has their own method certainly
and
i think even what you're saying about
tom coughlin right that goes back to
what we're saying about joe judge
yeah you can drive a hard bargain and be
a tough coach and do all that
but you got to show that you're willing
to bend i guess is what we're saying and
being able to willing to show your
listen to the players
and have a sympathetic ear a little bit
to the new ways of the world here in
2020 and what the modern day athlete is
and i think that's part of being the you
know the modern day coach in the nfl
right now
or you come out of the gates and win and
win and win and then you can do whatever
the hell you everything
right right do whatever you want
remember three years ago 2017 the first
year of doug maron in jacksonville right
he beat the hell out of those guys i
almost said a different word
he get a little too comfortable here at
the microphone he beat the hell out of
those guys
in training camp and they were grousing
and they were grumbling and then you
know what happened they started winning
games and they all shut up
now it's different now but uh but 2017
it worked
and they bought in because the the proof
was there once it was time to go
he's got some young leaders that i think
will buy in too that'll help joe judge
daniel jones a saquon i think they're
good guys that understand team and i
think that always goes a long way
throughout the team as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports